so langsam entsteht ein immer besseres
bild des mars wie er vor dreieinhalb
milliarden jahren ausgesehen haben muss
nämlich so eine zweite erde ein blauer
planet mit unmengen an wasser
das wurde jetzt durch den mars rover
curiosity wieder mal bestätigt er fand
nämlich am mount sharp dem krieg zum
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes seines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasste nichts
herzlich willkommen
es gibt immer mehr beweise der mars war
kein wüstenplanet sondern ein zweiter
blauer planet jetzt hat der mars-rover
cola sind sie tatsächlich leben auf dem
mars entdeckt in zwei bohrlöchern namens
ever lady und kim marie stieß der rover
aufleben es handelt sich um die 20 und
21 zu bohren von korea city und sie
enthalten die höchste je auf dem mars
gefundene menge an leben in einer
speziellen untersuchungseinheit von
colör city der chemie die die bohrkerne
auf die enthaltenen chemischen
verbindungen und mineralien untersucht
wurde das jetzt festgestellt es war die
erste analyse von bohrkernen aus dieser
leben haltigen schicht das in dieser
region leben existieren würde war schon
2012 vermutet worden jetzt hat curiosity
das bestätigt damit sind die bedingungen
in dieser region ideal gewesen damit
dort leben hätte existieren können die
hinweise auf lebensfreundliche
bedingungen verdichten sich also mal zu
mal an immer mehr stellen wird wasser
auf dem planeten gefunden und korea city
hat 2018 im selben gebiet auch komplexe
organische moleküle aufgespürt die
gleichen tiere gehen dass hier auf der
erde in erdöl und erdgas enthalten ist
und biologischen ursprungs ist und cork
city hat davon 100 mal mehr gefunden als
bisher
die forschungsgruppe vermutet einen
geologischen ursprung kann aber einen
biologischen nicht ausschließen sie
vermuten dass es nichts aus einem
meteoriten stammt womit die herkunft der
mars wäre
das wiederum nährt die hoffnung dass es
biologischen ursprungs sein könnte genau
an dieser stelle war vor milliarden
jahren ein see einen zuverlässigen
nachweis ob das material biologischen
oder geologischen ursprung ist das den
camcorder city nicht erbringen
vielleicht ist das noch mal mehr anreiz
möglichst bald weitere missionen zum
mars zu schicken die proben auch wieder
zurück zur erde schicken können um dann
den lehm und die anderen funde genauer
zu untersuchen denn dann könnten die
probleme in labors viel genauer
untersucht werden nur hier auf der erde
hätten wir die möglichkeit alle zur
verfügung stehenden untersuchungs
methoden anzuwenden um leben aufzuspüren
auf dem mars sind wir immer auf die
geräte angewiesen die mit an bord der
rover sind aber erstmal ist jetzt
exomars dran die sonde der europäischen
weltraumagentur esa wird sich in noch
tiefere gesteinsschichten bohren und
weitere erkenntnisse bringen
dort könnte dann auch eine wasser
leitende schicht entdeckt werden die
unter dem mars boden vermutet wird es
scheint sich immer mehr der verdacht zu
erhärten dass der mars einmal ein blauer
planet war und er wie hier auf der erde
auch leben beherbergte oder das
vielleicht immer noch tut methan spuren
in der atmosphäre könnten darauf
hindeuten allerdings ist noch unklar
warum sie so schwanken und das war ja
auch eine heftige studie leben auf dem
mars beweis durch diese fotos anklicken
anschauen und raumzeit lockt der zukunft
unbedingt abonnieren bis dahin bleibt
dran